I got Mia
you look at sales okay
um
thank you
so any uh
chair from councilor Burke yeah any
Declarations of Interest
so uh minutes of the last meeting
on green or whatever are we happy with
those minutes
are we all in favor of that minute Sam
thank you
lovely well thank you Kathy
Superior being in the room
um
a medium-term financial plan budget
monitoring report
thank you thank you very much purpose of
this report is to update cabinets on the
financial position the Council of
quarter three
indices one and two summarize the
general composition
the general fund is 177 000 under spent
after q1 the main variances are detailed
in the report two three to two five
utilities are currently lower than
forecast which is positive
and these are being revealed as part of
the budget
the cost of bed and breakfast is all is
higher than budget
a concerning position that was being
mirrored across the country
report approved in January including a
pay Award of four percent and currently
the employer's offer is an average of
6.5 percent
this will cost us a further 470 000 a
year which we'll need to consider as
part of the budget review
I think the only thing I would like to
mention are on the figures uh we noticed
killer Marsh Leisure Center was fairly
down in the first quarter it might be
cyclical that or it might be
a deeper problem we'll have to keep an
eye on that
there are very few variants just to note
on the HRA so I will point you to
appendix 3 which provides the q1
position
an appendix 4 deals with the capital
expenditure incurred on a scheme by
stream basis details of variance
variances can be found 2.15
I'm happy now James come to take any
question
the report
she won't add anything Jane no that's
fine thank you chair yeah any questions
playing on the finance I think that
somebody built I want him to note that
report I think there's a second part of
that Nigel
medium-term financial plan
it all was used to come as one report
that's it for the revised treasury
management code has made quarter report
reporting of indicators mandatory from
April
and whilst updates have been provided
for many years more detail
detail is now required therefore a
separate report for treasury management
will produce be produced alongside the
budgeting monitoring each quarter but
you will be pleased to note in the
report that there are no compliance
matters all risk raised this quarter
questions again and recommendation is to
note the report
yeah to go through it
right for work no I'm only joking so
glad you said that
it is yeah it's a heavy one it's the
same we will always have the report it's
the figures that we can go up to on the
ceiling it's uh where we get where we
loan money for short-term long term it's
just the mechanics of it
it's a paper exercise but they're all
there and the compliance was there yeah
thank you and I'm happy with it do we
need to move
agree that then well it's got to be said
if it's got with them
before yeah yeah it will give us two
items on the next agenda instead of a
one okay thank you yes so we normally
have an mtfp budget monitoring includes
the treasure number
thank you so we're all right
thank you great
uh
how would you steal them establishing
the local fun review working group
thank you chair yes this report is uh
establish that local plan working group
and it's to recommend that to the review
working group we established at the
council meeting on in September next
Monday
um to recommend the structural local
plan working group in terms of its
membership
um and to consider the merits and
recommendations
um other membership structure
um you know we haven't gone for we
wouldn't prefer I would prefer a
structure that's open represents all
parts of the council
um is a genuine working group
um and uh that's um itemized in the
report to 0.4
um and the recommendation is that the
cabinet recommends the council and the
25th of September the establishment of
the local plan working group in
accordance with the structure in terms
of reference detailed in appendix a
um do you want to say anything about
that
I'm happy to answer any questions or
talk through the report but not no
nothing else summarizes it well
thank you thank you any questions or
comments on on that
so we're
if I were checking that book out till
then on the exactly the recommendation
yet there is a there is a proposed
makeup appendix one yeah um which
relates to
um it relates to point four of the
options
um and I'm quite professional that
recommendation thank you Steve I'll take
that very all in favor
absolutely fine
thank you
is that all right
uh the decision of the Brampton Parish
neighborhood plan then been again
lock in that there is uh
the purpose this is to advise members on
the proposed of Brampton Parish
neighborhood plan and the findings of
the independent examiner
um which were very thorough and covered
a significant number of
points
um
the recommended modifications of the
examiner have been circulated
um it's the secure authorization the
following a successful referendum if
more than half of those voted voting
favors neighborhoods plan that that's
brought into effect uh it'll be made by
by this Authority and obviously now it's
got to go out to ref to a referendum in
Brampton with those recommendations made
by that external Examiner
um is there any comments um is Helen
here you want to make the independence
make any comments on that and can check
any questions okay do you want to yeah
just something to clarify on the
recommendation chair so um at the moment
iPhone 2 on the recommendation refers to
um delegating authority to myself and to
effectively deal with the um the process
after the the referendum
um in discussion with Sarah as
management officer um and Lee just to be
clear that Lee actually already has
delegated authority to do that so item
two effectively becomes null and void
from the recommendation uh so it's just
to clarify that point and also to
apologize for the numbering that seems
to go awry in section two that's uh
yeah I thought I should own up to it but
otherwise nothing to add unless there's
questions from members
uh no I think that's again so that's
exponentry but we aren't good with those
recommendations just recommendation one
that's correct yeah
don't blame me now
all in favor yeah
thank you Kathy you're welcome
absolutely Boys From Outer Space
North East Derbyshire UK share
Prosperity fund update James
[Music]
very good
oh yeah
of the report is pride members with an
update on the North East staff to UK
prosperity for the program
um and the recommendations are that
members are asked to note the content of
the report
and on that one I don't know if
anybody's any questions
it's just really obviously the paper
outlined the priorities in themes under
under each priority just to give you a
bit of background
with the investment plan that we had to
put in
um so if it was quite sort of fixed in
terms of the the Privacy thematic
um underpinning
um each one so it wasn't kind of like a
bit of a blank check so to speak um so
that drove quite a lot of the decision
making and as you can see the report
outlines how much we've got allocated to
each of the themes and what I have got
is a presentation so I can give you just
an overview of the financial context of
where we're at so far
so because we the approach we took was a
mixture of commissioned activity
activity that could be delivered through
um Council
um Offices here and also Grant schemes
so it was it was a real mixed kind of
bug approach in terms of how we're going
to deliver the investment plan
so
what I've just I've just pulled a few
slides together just to give you an
overview
s
[Music]
oh no
it's not always easy
um so the three
boaty areas plus the management and
admin total to 2.568 that we rewarded
through the investment plan and next
slide please
next one
so
what what I've done with this is just to
give you a feel for the theme and the
detail indicates who the beneficiaries
are if we know at this point in time so
for the public realm they're still
officer working in terms of identifying
what will happen on field so dronfield
was identified as a priority when the
investment plan was being written it was
a half a million allocated for that
with postparts and Open Spaces we had
two um Grant funds um that we ran
um back to back that was open to Parish
Town council's only so that wasn't open
to the public
green rooms we've not identified any
sites yet of where we can
um invest the 30 grand but that work is
is underway and we were working with
Dutch County council's butchericide
agency is what it could say sorry
service to identify if there's any kind
of privacy use of this group that made
anything from that
um just your kind of improvement so this
is just on our feasibility study that
we're training for this it hopefully
will demonstrate that
um if there are improvements made to the
canal what are the results and economic
impacts for other areas of the you know
the killer Marsh
Etc and where we could potentially uh uh
you know develop kind of Tourism uh
cultural activities and what have you
the community activities so this um our
community safety team so Faye Green's
team is delivering this strand so this
is targeted intervention known under
social behavior hot spots across the
district are so far uh there's been a
variety of extreme Wheels I don't know
if it's a um a concept that you're
familiar with
um it tends to be quite successful and
attracts a lot of young people
um and kind of like you know really good
in terms of engaging with them so that
will carry on for the duration of the
program till March 25
um next time Achilles
um and an inclusive community so this
was an open Grant scheme that we run at
the beginning of this year and this has
helped support vulnerable household
um and Community to provide advice
support and um what have you so we have
three successful applications that came
from citizens advice Northeast
Derbyshire so they provide um a
specialist energy advice for residents
uh Mercier provide digital free digital
training and this complemented an
existing projects that we were used
money to get off the ground and so it
was about building capacity essentially
and then Derbyshire voluntary action
they um already doing quite a lot of
work in terms of reducing social
isolation
um and what this project well this
element of project was about building
volunteer capacity so you know once the
funding ends that could be trained
trained volunteers to establish groups
get the groups running
um and then that just creates its own
kind of sustainable model and there's
also another element to that which is
about
um uh so it's a budding scheme it's like
social connectors so primarily looking
at um supporting old people particularly
vulnerable people that may not for
whatever reason
um confidence or Mobility want to leave
the house so it's about just providing
that one-to-one support initially
building the confidence connecting them
to various groups whether it's a local
Bingo group down the road or anything
better and just building those social
collections up for them
uh enhancement Village Halls so this was
open to
um Parish parishes and Community venues
and this was just trying to put in a
fairly small scale improvements but that
would enhance the quality of the
building to help increase higher
um you know kind of um uh higher usage
footfalls and there's also an element of
Energy Efficiency so whether it's kind
of energy efficient lines energy
lighting improving Windows
um and exploring the district it is
about you know boosting tourism boosting
the culture for the district
um it's quite early days with that and
that will run for the duration of the
project as well but we've got economic
development team and our conference team
working together on progress in that
um
um so from a look from the local
business priority we've got two uh
thematic areas so we've got the shop
Frontage scheme which some of you may
have already seen promoted
um
substantial it is district-wide
um and um they are starting to get
expressions of Interest through
um it's a little bit I'm not complicated
but there's a degree um engagement
planning
um because some elements will require
planning consent so I know cursed in
economic development is working really
closely with the planning team to make
sure that that process is seamless as
possible for applicants
um and then the dedicated business
advice and guidance uh that was a it's a
collaborative process with how many of
the local authorities five so five
across the county
um and it's gone out to Tender are we
allowed to say who they are
yeah yeah okay so um Chamber of Commerce
has won the tender for that it's just
the contracts in the final stages of
being signed
um so that work will start shortly as
soon as the the um legal bits are in
place
and then the last strung people and
skills and so this is green energy so
this is about upskilling existing trades
people to help diversify in to
um sustainable energies you know so um
they can learn how to fit solar PV
panels electric charging points
um
so just to give you a flavor of of where
we're at
um so the 2.4 million see there just
exclusive management and admin so far
we've spent
um 480
000 and so that's cumulative from the
last quarter over the last Financial
year up to quarter one so we're just
about to start the monitoring cycle for
the next quarter so we're about three
months out of date these figures but
we've not got to the end of the
monitoring period yet
so far in terms of what we've got
committed we've got 1.6 million so that
that's what we've got what we know we're
going to be spending between now and the
end of program March 25.
the potential to reallocate this
represents conditional agreements that
we've provided to um so you see the 274
for which parts are there with Parish
councils at the minute so they've got
until the end of September to meet the
conditions that we've set out and that
could be a combination of securing
additional match funding or having to
rescope the project because the grant
we've awarded wasn't as big as what
they'd applied for so we've given them a
few months to just kind of read redesign
the scheme so at the end of the month
we'll know who's in a priority who's in
a position to meet those additional
um
who's working towards them so if it all
went horribly wrong
and they basically turned around and
said no we really sorry we can't accept
the brand it's 174 to go back to the
part I should say that just includes a
significant lunch break Park in
eckington so they've had an opportunity
to put in an application which is due at
the end of this month so that's mostly
it's fun for them to be a month for
lunch free
um in the report there's a chance that
at some point they need to talk about
recommendations to how to perhaps
utilize the
um the small amount um just shy of 8 000
for enhancer Village Halls of the
applications we awarded only one was
unable to accept we just waited for a
rescope in terms of what what their
proposal is what they can do with the
money again that's the end of this month
so depending on what they come back with
that could be some money in the pot
29 000 for inclusive communities that is
remains and allocated we did have
applications that exceeded what we'd got
in the park but some of the applications
duplicated what we you know other
activity so
um so that needs to be committed so at
some point once we get to the end of the
month and we'll see where we're at
globally with what we've got left to
spend we can then come together with
proposals about how to allocate that but
other than that as you can see
significant proportion is committed
we're already spending
um so hopefully that just gives you a
bit of confidence that when we're on
we're on with it essentially and next
slide please
[Music]
um
yes so that's it so absolutely questions
that's great and like I say it does make
it some interest I think the the you
know for various places
just explain I think to the committee
about
that we've got to be spent by March 25
in itself with that that money's not
there forever that's right that's
correct because there's always this
question that that
people
assume that they've got that a lot of
apparently can't suspend that and it
that time's coming around very quickly
it is it is so what we've done
particularly with the grant scheme so
so just to give you some reassurance
with the quality parks and Village Halls
we've asked applicants the financially
the Project's complete by December 24.
now fortunately because of the nature of
the schemes they're quite most of them
are quite short sharp projects whether
it's upgrading play equipment putting
LED lighting
um the projects that will take a little
bit longer there's still enough time but
that's why we've given this September
deadline to confirm if they can meet the
the out
um the conditions that we've put in the
grant funding agreement but we we will
review it on a case-by-case basis that
if if there is a parish council that's
saying look we can't give you a
definitive however we've got all our
ducks lined up
by November December then I'm sure we
can take a pragmatic approach but we've
had to give that deadline because then
if we do get to the end of the calendar
year and it looks like there will be
money unallocated we've got to decide on
I've got to give people enough time to
be able to do something with that
whether it's relaunching or the grant
scheme or finding another way to
reallocate that funding so is it tight
yes is it unmanageable no at this moment
in time ask me again in six months and
then you say we is that or is that the
cabinet yes so so what I'll probably
like I alluded to in the report that
we'll if we find ourselves in a position
where we've got unallocated funding we
can bring proposals back to Cabinet
um and then you know explore the
different options of of how to to kind
of utilize that funding yeah it doesn't
go twice we don't send it back
contingency time so that's why we've
asked specifically with the capital
schemes that by December 24th that
schemes had gone so if for whatever
reason
at winter
etc etc there's a little bit of
breathing space but obviously it's only
three months but um but yeah what's not
spent by March 25 has to go back
at this moment in time that's what we're
that's what we've been led to believe
well that's that's fine for that yeah
thank you so we just note in
yeah it's just about the progress today
yeah no no decisions thank you for that
okay and well done
it's terrible I'm going to give money
away
we're all in developing that are you
happy with that yeah thank you
uh now we're going to introduce this one
I think Alan and
into borrowing Community sector
infrastructure
and then we need to go into private
session now for instance yes chair it's
likely at that point that because we've
got representatives from those voluntary
groups here about information which
needed to be exempt will be discussed so
therefore public will need to be
excluded and the stream will stop at
that point but members will be asked to
move a formal exclusion of public good
I think I need you to change to it all
I've got is what's written many papers
so the the purpose and the summary
um about providing an overview of the
outcomes that have achieved between 2022
and 2023 Trish will have more detail on
that than that yeah essentially you saw
the report last time
I presented the report so we outline
in the um Financial year 2223 so this
concludes the monitoring process for
essentially the previous Financial year
um so what we um historically what we've
done and what we've restarted this year
is that we've given the opportunity for
organizations to
um contaminate and explain far better
than I could ever articulate in in my
room for being the parents the you know
the whole premise that we provide to
development the impact it has for the
history and the residents of the
district and so this is the book of it
at that point then
can I move I have to read all this yeah
the publicly gets loaded from the
meeting during discussion of the
following art in the business to avoid
the disclosure to them of exempt
information
has defined in part one of schedule 12a
to the Local Government Act 1972.
as amended by the local government
access to information
variation order
2006. I still waiting yeah the category
of exempt information is stated after
each item
thank you
I will switch off now what do we all
leave